on va passer à l'autre thème de ce club
on va parler d'eric zemmour le nom
candidat presque candidat pas encore
candidat mais bientôt candidat puisque
il a dit hier que c'était clair dans sa
tête eric zemmour qui a fait plusieurs
propositions il a parlé notamment des 90
km heure du permis à points on va
revenir mais alex il a aussi fait des
propositions sur le sujet de
l'immigration des propositions assez
radical émigrés de création sujet au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle à
droite et des mots et la multiplie les
propositions pour durcir les conditions
de vie des étrangers oui c'est
clairement l'idée eric zemmour qu'hier
et bien est revenu sur sa proposition de
ne plus verser des aides sociales aux
étrangers sur le sol français
allocations logement allocations
familiales rsa pour finalement réservé
ces aides sociales uniquement aux
français écoutez le ci je ne discrimine
pas entre français et étrangers ça veut
dire que la nation n'existe pas ça ne
sert à rien d'avoir la france si on et
étrangers ou français c'est la même
chose non ce n'est pas la même lignée
que zémogo solidarité nationale dans la
être maintenu et réservé aux français
alors toujours dans sa logique de durcir
les conditions de vie des étrangers en
france eric zemmour propose que les
étrangers qui ont eu un travail mais qui
se retrouvent au chômage n'est pas une
reconduction automatique de leur carte
de séjour écoutez ils ont cotisé pour le
chômage ils deviennent chômeurs vous
leur dites vous rentrez chez vous du
moment où vous êtes et vous avez de
chômeurs ça veut pas dire qu'on leur
payera pas ce qu'ils ont cotisé le bilan
de leur cotisation mais chez eux
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des pays aux
états unis ça ne vous choque pas aux
états unis vous êtes chômeur vous n'avez
plus votre green card et vous repartez
très loin sur cette proposition lors
emmené il va plus loin que marine le pen
n'est encore sûr sur ces questions
étrangers et la location a réservé aux
étrangers est-ce qu'il peut aller trop
loin ou est ce que c'est un discours qui
peut parler une certaine partie de la
population je pense que zemmour il aime
bien prendre marine le pen par la droite
aussi nous voilà donc ça c'est une de
ces stratégies il joue un billard à
trois bandes in vitro 3 électorat eric
zemmour il vise à la fois de l iphone à
la fois les voix de marine le pen qui
arrive plutôt bien à faire en tout cas
une certaine ils siphonnent évidemment
les voix de l air la partie la plus
droite plr les fillonnistes on va dire
tout ce qui était mariage pour tous etc
enfin anti mariage pour tous et il
cherche aussi un peu à mobiliser dans
l'abstentionnisme donc à ce jeu là
effectivement il a des mesures
extrêmement radical là on est en dire en
plein délire oui en plein délire c'est à
dire que là on
l'interdiction arrêter les prestations
sociales pour les étrangers même en
situation régulière je pense que c'est
jamais entendu je ne suis pas sûr de la
constitutionnalité de aussi de cette
mesure et surtout je sais même pas au
point de vue économique d'ailleurs si
des des entrepreneurs du medef qui
pourraient se retrouver proche de
zemmour le souhaitent voilà j'ai encore
envie très récemment qu'ils avaient des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre et des
attentes en termes de l'immigration sur
les questions économiques que le medef
réclame presque porte-à-faux là dessus
mais il son but c'est d'aller le plus
loin possible pour choquer le plus
l'agent imagine que ils y arrivent
effectivement il a pas parlé de la
question économique air lui il a mis ça
sur le plan de la nation édition réserve
pas la semaine de la solidarité
nationale aux français il ya plus de
nation wyffels les tensions
couloir je ne dis rien de de surprenant
dans son entretien dire chez vos
confrères
effectivement il est il est dans son
couloir qui est entre le rassemblement
national et les orphelins du fils honni
oui mais pas seulement aussi est
orphelin je dirais de la droite en
général donc là-dessus il n'y a
absolument rien de surprenant et il va
continuer à dérouler sa campagne
manifestement un comme bon lui semble
200 se faire dicter par les polémiques
part parce que ces propos par les
réactions que ses propos peuvent
engendrer donc à pour moi rien de
surprenant dans ce que dans ce que enfin
dans la stratégie en tout cas d'eric
zemmour eux lire et puisque vous parlez
de la droite justement on va en parler
avec vous alex puisque hier gérard
larcher il a réagi au positionnement des
règlements alors pas cette proposition
particulière puisqu'elle est arrivé
après mais dans le journal du dimanche
il reconnaît que la droite a échoué sur
cette question d'immigration mais
sexuellement le président du sénat fait
une sorte de mea culpa il reconnaît un
échec collectif autour de ces questions
de l'immigration de la sécurité et
finalement il analyse la poussée d'eric
zemmour dans les sondages regarder ce
qu'il dit eric zemmour c'est un miroir
que nous tendent des millions de
français qui nous reprochent de
renoncement sur la question migratoire
sur la sécurité sur l'identité et gérard
larcher estime que si la droite veut
gagner la présidentielle et bien elle
doit faire des propositions de solides
sur le sujet migratoires et c'est ce
qu'il essaye de faire dans cette
interview il propose de mettre en place
une immigration choisie selon les
métiers et selon les pays il veut
également revoir les accords bilatéraux
avec les états non coopératifs et
souhaite que les demandes d'asile se
fasse dans les ambassades ou alors à la
frontière pour et bien éviter les
l'immigration clandestine donc des
propositions de gérard larcher pour
contre eric zemmour et on sent bien que
gérard larcher n'a pas eric zemmour dans
son coeur il considère que l'idh
l'éditorialiste et bien abîme la nation
avec son discours fracturé la société se
résume finalement et bien en une phrase
a hissé vous les uns les autres et puis
on a un autre dans la famille politique
de droite qui est aussi très virulent
face à eric zemmour c'est le maire de
nice christian estrosi toujours au
journal du dimanche il dit et bien le
fait un appel aux gaullistes
ressaisissez-vous il faut combattre ses
anathèmes de toutes nos forces et
réaffirmer l'attachement au droit du sol
et puis il est aussi dur avec la droite
il dit suite été à la droite dont eczéma
entend siphonner les électeurs de mener
la riposte elle a déserté ce combat on
rappelle que christian estrosi a annoncé
qu'il voterait emmanuel macron à la
présidentielle
de mea culpa si on peut dire ça comme ça
le rend médias dans le jdd de la part de
personnalités de droite qu'est ce qu'il
faut y voir il faut y voir mais moi ce
qui m'inquiète un petit peu c'est la
faculté de la droite à coire les thèmes
de zemmour est certes on peut faire un
mea culpa enfin ils font leur mea culpa
mais sur quoi c'est à dire qu'ils
trouvent qu'ils n'ont pas été assez dur
sur l'immigration j'ai la droite a
toujours à droitiser son discours depuis
quand nicolas sarkozy sur ces questions
là ils sont restés dans cette droite
ligne et je trouve que cette course à
l'échalote est extrêmement dangereuse
parce que ils donnent du crédit aussi
aux thématiques de d'eric zemmour sur
ces questions là alors qu'on est dans
quelque chose d'absolument
terrible finalement dans ce qu'il
annonce effectivement c'est une remise
en cause du droit du sol c'est des
choses comme ça la droite devrait aussi
être un peu plus vindicative sur le fond
de ces propositions et non pas de dire
ah bah oui on n'a pas assez parlé
d'immigration où on n'a pas été assez
dur sur l'immigration non il faut qu'ils
nous position beaucoup plus ferme sur
les thématiques sur cette thématique là
pour arrêter le faire penser que ce que
raconte eric zemmour et la réalité comme
si l'immigration était le problème alpha
et oméga de la france aujourd'hui france
a toujours été une terre d'immigration
depuis des dévoila des siècles
l'immigration n'est pas un problème ni
économique ni politique de grande
ampleur est il ce n'est même pas un
problème donc donner du crédit la droite
a une responsabilité là dedans que moi
je trouve assez gras possible et du coup
la question ce même club suite à ce que
vient vers l'europe
il est en train de droitiser la compagne
présidentielle
il vient en train en tout cas depuis un
certain temps d'en poser les thèmes et
c'est le seul on voit bien que la
majorité des candidats pas tous mais la
majorité réagissent à ce que 10 eric
zemmour est pour l'instant c'est lui
avec deux trois autres qui impose ses
propres thèmes la preuve c'est que
gérard larcher bonjour ne reviens pas
sur ce qu a dit christian estrosi parce
qu'ils votent à mâcon etc il n'y a pas
de sujet mais si gérard larcher n'est
pas
les candidats rien aujourd'hui et c'est
lui qui vient faire des prix
tout ça est un petit peu étrange en fait
enfin je comprends pas pourquoi on
n'entend pas ou peu
les propositions de ce qui se présente
en fait là on entend gérard larcher
pourquoi comment je j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre mais
est-ce qu'ils droitise la campagne
il impose c'est aime ça c'est sûr est ce
que le pays aussi ne s'est pas droitiser
est ce que dans par certaines paroles
des manuels macro également il n'y a pas
eu une volonté en tout cas d'essayer de
droitiser je pense que la question est
beaucoup plus large et aujourd'hui dire
que c'est la faute à eric zemmour si la
droite n'y arrive pas si les scores sont
faibles à droite c'est un petit peu
facile aussi un dernier mot sur un autre
sujet mais quand même pas eric zemmour
alors il a fait cette proposition serbes
dont on a longuement parlé mais il a
aussi dit qu'il voulait revenir aux 90
kilomètres heure qui voulaient empêcher
les maires de passer aux 30 km heure qui
voulait mettre fin au permis un point
est ce qu en plus de vouloir conquérir
l'électorat de droite s'il essaye
d'apporter une réponse au gilet jaune
tout à fait là il est sur les
thématiques voilà des gilet jaune
justement des côtes et on m'appellerait
des tracasseries du quotidien et puis
voilà extrêmement de manière
injuste aussi le permis à points voilà
c'est pas et ça n'a pas été une mesure
aussi qui a été mauvaise pour la
sécurité routière voilà donc c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est pas du tout étayé
intellectuellement et politiquement mais
c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui fait
plaisir à entendre peut-être pour une
certaine frange de l'électorat et de
manière assez assez grossière parce que
franchement c'est quand même voilà on
voit bien on le voit bien venir et il
essaye d'aller sur le terrain des gilet
jaune
je sais je pense que ça peut prendre à
mon avis c'est quelque chose qui va
faire en tout cas par les polémiques et
je pense qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de
sujets sur les 30 km heure sur le permis
à points et voilà ça va continuer à
faire beaucoup de buzz autour de lui
[Musique]